Hey, it's now a good time to talk.
I know we kinda argued before bed, and we, like,
tried to make up,
but it feels kinda like I feel now this morning.
Kinda like I just squashed some of my feelings
to kinda make it go away,
but they're still kinda bothering me.
And I was wondering if we could just talk, you know?
So you're saying you lied to me last night?
That's the real fucking issue.
You're constant fucking lying.
You told me everything was okay.
You told me you forgave me,
and now we gotta bring it back up again.
Now we gotta do it all over again,
you know? You're never fucking happy.
I work my ass to the bone for this family,
and what do you do?
Fucking complain all the fucking time?
Why don't you stay sitting on your ass all day
like I know you're gonna.
Well, I fucking work.